I tell everyone I got laid off from a
job because of pay cuts but I got fired
because I stole people's food from the
fridge no regrets I got fired from
Starbucks for drawing it to dick on a
girl's caramel macchiato
she called quarters I'm gonna call
corporate day I got fired for making out
with my boyfriend when he stopped by
work I got fired because of a work
selfie whatever I got fired for always
calling in sick
just so I could stay home and play
Skyrim I still have no regrets one time
I got sick at work and drank what I
thought was dayquil but ended up being
nyquil and I got fired for being drunk
on the job right here I got fired from
my first job because I would get high
and taste the fries like you wouldn't I
was fired because I had sex my office
after hours my major yeah he was upset
too I was fired because I couldn't
staple papers to my boss's status family
what is that I used to dress up as
Prince Eric at Disneyland parades for
five years until I got fired for doing
porn on the side
stare back see what the big deal was